ich möchte jetzt aber noch auf eine
programmänderung hinweisen denn wir
haben unser programm umgestellt weil uns
die meldung erreicht hat dass roma
villen sind gestorben ist 60 jahre alt
ist er geworden und er starb an krebs
weil kollege alfred schier hat vor
einigen jahren ein gespräch mit diesen
brillanten deutschen intellektuellen
geführt
heute im dialog alfred schier mit roger
willemsen
er galt als kunstvollste und gebildeter
unter den fernseh talk und durch diese
phase ist längst vorbei er hat dem
medium den rücken gekehrt inzwischen
macht der vorträge kabarett und schreibt
bücher herzlich willkommen bei phoenix
kakashi warum haben sie dem fernsehen
rücken gekehrt
das fernsehen und ich hatten uns stärker
auseinander entwickelt als kurt felix
und paola glaube ich es ist irgendwann
der zeitpunkt gekommen wo man denkt dass
es keine tätigkeit für erwachsene mehr
jedenfalls in dem format in dem ich
arbeiten durfte über das fernsehen kann
man viele menschen erreichen ist das
nicht reizvoll
viele menschen von dem zu überzeugen
wovon man selbst überzeugt ist das ist
es aber ich hab mal behauptet die wahren
tabus des fernsehens sind nicht sex und
tod weil darüber wird wirklich viel
geredet sondern leninismus grillparzers
spätwerk die druckgrafik von cranach und
so weiter
das heißt meine interessen waren immer
eher minderheiten interessen und
minderheiten interessen in einem
massenmedium zu vermitteln ist mühevoll
das heißt nicht dass ich die mühle nicht
wertvoll finde oder dass ich nicht denke
man sollte sie schultern
aber insgesamt ist es einfacher und ist
es auch leidenschaftlich und präziser
ist bühnen zu tun
jetzt wollen wir ja auch nicht zu lange
über das reden was sie nicht mehr tun
sondern über das reden was sie tun sie
haben ein buch geschrieben kommt diese
woche auf den markt die enden der welt
wo endet die welt sie endet
wahrscheinlich von einem gewissen ende
aus betrachtet sogar in diesem
fernsehstudio also zum beispiel sagt das
inselreich tonga wo ich gewesen bin und
man nimmt einen raum diagonale durch den
globus und kommt in dongguan in
polynesien die sagen das ende der welt
ist deutschland hamburg vielleicht sogar
also es geht ihnen nicht um bestimmten
ort auf dieser welt das ist ja auch
wirklich ganz eindrucksvoll ihre reise
schilderungen so zu ganz
unterschiedlichen orten auf dieser welt
tonga in der südsee haben sie schon
angesprochen sie waren am nordpol sie
waren in timbuktu in der sahara sie war
in kathmandu im himalaya
was haben sie dann gesucht wissen sie
ich war seit frühen tagen eigentlich
immer angezogen von landschaften die mir
leer stehen und wo manchmal erhabene
menschen sich selber überlassen sind wo
der mensch noch in der defensive vor der
natur ist und wo es was süßes was
unbehauen es gibt dann gibt es aber auch
die weniger offensichtlichen enden der
welt also ein bordell flur in bombay wo
ich ganz am ende eines flurs eine 19
jährige prostituierte sehe die sowohl
aids krank ist wie auch schwachsinnig
und die wie ein orakel da thront und
dann und wann den freier annimmt und
ihnen manchmal ablehnt sie ist nur noch
gut für freier die auch als krank sind
oder die ungeschützten verkehr haben
wollen
diese frau zu sehen die nun manchmal den
männern furchtbar gut tut und manchmal
furchtbar schreit weil sie sie ablehnt
das hat etwas was einen an die letzte
klasse der menschheit erinnert wo man
denkt hier geht es nicht mehr tiefer
weiter entfernt aus der gesellschaft der
menschheit kann man sich nicht raus
promovieren als an diesem ort und die
diese existenz formen auch das was damit
verbunden ist da an eigene grenzen zu
kommen
das hat mich fasziniert sie können ja
auch sagen dieses in die welt wollen das
hängt immer auch zusammen mit aus der
welt raus wollen und dazwischen hängt
liegen die enden der welt
wüstenlandschaften leben
jetzt haben sie da gerade was was
angesprochen bei dieser erzählung von
bombay
das ist mir mehrfach aufgefallen diese
orte die sie besuchen die sind sehr
exotische aber die haben manchmal
mythischen klang indien hätte man
faszinierende orte finden können und sie
schildern ein völlig trostloses bordell
warum sind diese orte die sie da
besuchen warum ist die schilderung so
häufig so trostlos einer sind die enden
der welt die mir so erscheinen nicht
sehenswürdigkeiten
da sammelt sich der massentourismus der
massentourismus ist am kap in afrika zum
beispiel wie ein boden bedeckt der
überall nur noch souvenirs ausbreitet
aber in der zone davor wo die natur die
menschen sich selber überlassen sind
oder in einer chilenischen stadt wo ein
vulkan ausgebrochen ist die stadt ist
abgesperrt man darf nicht mehr rein ich
komme mit einer sondergenehmigung da
rein und sehe
dass das krankenhaus besteck noch da
liegt aber staub bedeckt und dass die
pferde durch die stadt strömen und die
stadt mehr oder weniger übernommen haben
halbe wildpferde
das sind orte die haben was menschen
abgekehrt ist da hat man das gefühl man
kommt auf der rückseite einer landschaft
an und das ist wie bei einer stickerei
wo die fäden draußen hängen und man hat
nicht mehr so viel farbe aber es gibt
etwas wesentliches an diesen
landschaften
das klingt in mir nach ich glaube es ist
so eine banalität immer zu sagen alle
reisen führen immer ins eigene innere
und mich haben diese landschaft immer
stärker angezogen als die die allein
prachtvoll sind und von denen man fotos
machen ich würde trotzdem gern noch mal
über diese trostlosigkeit reden noch zum
beispiel skifahren mit einem russischen
eisbrecher in eine reisegesellschaft an
den nordpol und diese ganze reise ist
auch schon wieder so so trist also die
meisten reisebegleiter sind eher trübe
menschen dann gibt es eine person eine
frau der sie etwas näher kommen die
begeht selbstmord und am ende kommen sie
dann am nordpol an und erwarten
natürlich wie wir das alle machen würden
eine verschneite vereiste landschaft und
dann regnet dabei drei grad plus
irgendwie alles enttäuschung trostlos es
ist beides also die bilder vom nordpol
sind sollte von denen ich glaube die
sich auf dem sterbebett wieder weil ich
fand die landschaft grandios ich hätte
niemals gedacht dass ich zwölf stunden
an bord eines schiffes stehe und mir nur
monochrome landschaft angucke treibende
wolken enkels kreis kultur an regelrecht
und dann passiert so was eine frau sagte
meinen patagonien zu mir wissen sie hier
entwickeln sich die geschichten gerne
dramatisch und die einzige frau die nun
meine gesellschaft sucht und die ich
anfange so ein bisschen zu studieren und
mit der ich ihn sehr komplizierte
unterhaltung eintrete diese frau
verschwindet nach fünf tagen in dem sie
ins eis sprengt und die dann in weiß wie
eine christusstatue geborgen wird und
von einem kran hochgezogen wird
und jetzt muss diese gruppe aus 80
expeditionsteilnehmer erstens mit einem
selbstmord fertig werden und tut das oft
mit zum teil sehr archaische weise
zweitens wird das schiff beschädigt bei
der vollbremsung und kann plötzlich
nicht mehr weiter fahren wir liegen also
mit einem
lego schiffchen mitten im eis das sofort
von dem schiff besitz ergreift und
wissen gar nicht können wir uns noch
überhaupt weiter bewegen und in dieser
situation im extrem eine situation in
der normalerweise polarforscher ihr
leben riskiert haben zerfällt diese
luxus gruppe und erhebt ansprüche und
sagt ich werde jetzt regresspflicht
anmelden und ich will sofort weg
gebracht werden und so weiter das
interessiert mich dann sowohl was die
größe der landschaft angeht die zum
haben gehört was ich gesehen habe in
meinem leben aber auch zu dem was
menschen aus der situation machen ich
bin ja nicht grundsätzlich ein anderer
ich bin ein beobachter und wenn es
regnet am nordpol da muss ich sagen das
ist klimaerwärmung auf den jüngsten
stand gebracht wir denken das ewiges eis
in wirklichkeit sind das treibende
schollen auf denen sich eisbären
befinden die doch nicht sein sollten und
die sich da eigentlich gar nicht
ernähren könnten wenn andere menschen
ihre reiseziele aussuchen dann suchen
sie häufig einfach schönen ort eine
schöne insel ein traumziel wie haben sie
ihre orte ausgesucht
ich bin ursprünglich auch so gereist ich
war mal ein halbes jahr in südostasien
und hab mich treiben lassen und ich bin
immer meiner witterung gefolgt ich bin
auch häufiger in situationen einfach
eingetreten die sich boten also einmal
in polynesien erinnere ich mich hat sich
einen arm aus einem toyota pickup mehr
entgegen gestreckt und ich sah nicht an
wem dieser arm befestigt war sonnig
schlug ein und dachte du bleibst in
dieser hand liegen mit einer hand und an
brothers ein zwei zentner schwerer in
dem gesicht tätowierter rugby spieler
mit dem ich in den nächsten zehn tagen
über die inseln gezogen bin und man geht
auch als jemand der so zumindest ein
reporter gehen noch hat geht man in
solche situationen hinein und fragt sich
was geschieht jetzt und am ende bin ich
mit dem bei einer beerdigung gewesen und
habe verpasst dass das schiff aus dass
ich eigentlich gebucht war untergegangen
ist und ich wäre an bord dieses schiffes
gewesen wenn ich den mann nicht
kennengelernt hätte also solche
verpflichtungen gibt es aber nicht reizt
das primär attraktive also die
sehenswürdigkeit alleine die reizt mich
weniger als das was immer an orten ist
was bleibt so würde ich auch den
touristen vom reisenden unterscheiden
der touristen einen schnappschuss machen
schnell wieder weg ich und die hagia
sophia
ich und der nächste tempel der reisen
bleibt verschwindet und sagt was ist
hier wenn ich nicht da bin
dieses reisen ist ja ein uralter
menschheitstraum und goethe ist nach
italien gereist heute gibt es den
massentourismus nach mallorca ist das
was komplett unterschiedliche sie hat ja
gerade schon unterschied gemacht
oder gibt es da doch was gemeinsam es
zwischen ihnen goethe und den mallorca
reisen denn das was uns da alle bewegt
was wir suchen erkenntnis abwechslung
flucht aus dem alltag die die suche nach
mir selber ja wissen sie diese oft ist
es die sprache die das aufhebt wir sagen
jemand ist erfahren und da steckt das
wort fahren drin
wir sagen jemand ist bewandert darin
steckt drin dass die früher reiseform
das wandern war die app grenze der
antiken welt wovon die antike gesagt hat
hier hört alles auf war das sogenannte
non plus ultra das non-plus-ultra waren
die beiden säulen da stand eine in
gibraltar und eine in nordafrika es
waren die sogenannten säulen des
herkules
man hat gesagt dahinter ist keine welt
kennen wir nichts dass das non plus
ultra niedriger ausfällt
genau dann gibt es eine zeichnung auf
einem buch von francis bacon und da ist
der einzige der hinter diesen säulen
noch reist odysseus und deshalb also
befindet sich jenseits der bekannten
welt und ich glaube nicht goethe alleine
sondern man ist als reisender gerade
auch wenn man den neuesten stand sucht
wenn man gegenwärtiges sucht wenn man
versucht irgendwo wirklich zu werden
nicht in folkloretänzen zu erstarren
nicht nur andenken zu erwerben dann ist
man immer ein bisschen auch dass dabei
reisen meistens allein weil ich nur als
alleinreisender in situationen eintreten
in denen die menschen von mir besitz
ergreifen indem ich plötzlich
vereinnahmt werde ich sagen wir mal so
ich riskiere mehr ich riskiere auch
ziemlich dramatische zustände von
einsamkeit ich riskiere auch wie etwa im
süden sibiriens dass eine ganze stadt
sagt hau ab du hast hier nichts zu
suchen und weil ich keine kyrillische
schrift lesen kann kriege ich nicht mehr
was zu essen also es gibt bestimmte
situationen in denen es elend wird
irgendwo im staub zu legen und wieder
mal schlecht zu schlafen oder irgendwie
nicht zu wissen wie man sich
am besten ernährt oder retten kann von
irgendwo aber das ist das drama was dann
zum reisen meter zugehört und ich liebe
auch das letztlich es tauchen in ihren
reise schilderungen ja ab und an frauen
auf aber auch diese begegnung mit den
frauen haben auf mich doch doch eher
ernüchternd gewirkt hat ist auch mal die
rede von romanze oder liebelei aber
liebe das wort kommt nicht ein einziges
mal vor
vielleicht weil ich die liebe wenn es
sie denn gäbe schützen würde vor dem
publikum wäre sie weniger teil dieses
reisen aber es stimmt es gibt zum
beispiel eine episode in der ich in
tokio sehr einsam werde und eine frau
anrufe die ich kenne und ich sage zu ihr
ich würde so gerne bahn fahren mit dir
und sie sagt gutmann und ich sage ihnen
drei wochen treffen uns auf dem
dammtorbahnhof in hamburg und wenn du
willst werden wir dann einen zug
besteigen und wir fahren quer durch
deutschland quer durch frankreich quer
durch spanien und fahren eben zu den
säulen des herkules zum nonplusultra
und ich weiß bis 10 minuten vorher nicht
ob die frau an den bahnhof erscheinen
wird und sie erscheint und wir fangen an
zu reißen und wir schlafen irgendwo
hinter den bahnhöfen spielen wird
flipper in den pyrenäen und wir haben
uns immer weniger zu sagen
und während die landschaft immer
rasanter wird und uns mit immer mehr
fremde einhüllt haben wir uns immer
weniger zu sagen und die kommunikation
magath allmählich ab und wir werden uns
am ende fast unsympathisch und sie sagt
je länger man mit der reist um so
schwieriger wirst du und sie hat sich
dann im süden spaniens von mir
verabschiedet und ich bin alleine hinter
die säulen des herkules gereist also das
ist das innere drama der reise aber das
korrespondiert auch dem was was alles
passierte ich hab da mal ein zitat von
ihnen gefunden das sagen sie über sich
selbst es gibt bei mir eine mangelnde
bereitschaft mich auf paarbeziehungen
einzulassen sagt er wahrscheinlich ich
bin marotten haft geworden schwer
vermittelbar und für bestimmte
sag mal gesellschaftliche situationen
nicht so gut geeignet ich kann sehr gut
mit mir selber das heißt pathetisch
gesprochen jede gesellschaft in die ich
trete muss sich damit messen wie gerne
ich mit mir alleine bin ich kann an
jedem abend wählen was sie besser haben
sie noch nie die richtige gefunden oder
sind sie gerne der einsame wollt also
heute habe ich sie gewählt und ich finde
das ist nicht schlecht und ich bin ganz
gerne einsam ich gehe wenig in
gesellschaften ich hab' ich würde doch
weil mir das aufgefallen ist noch gerne
eine geschichte aus dem buch heraus
greifen das ist die von clarisse china
erzählt um was es da geht es ist eine
frau die ich in einer wiener
nationalbibliothek kennenlernen und die
mit mir eigentlich kontakt aufnimmt
indem sie einen zettel vor mich legte
auf dem steht einfach unser mann aus
kairo ist am bahnhof angekommen und ich
fange an mich mit dieser frau zu
befreunden und sie scheint mir
wunderlich sie forscht über kraft gab
und sie ist besessen davon dass man sich
muss auslöschen können aushungern wie es
bei kafka passiert und in einer
liebesszene zwischen uns in der sie
plötzlich etwas offenbart es zeugen
möchte und ich plötzlich merke sie es
außerhalb meiner welt und sie ist auch
vielleicht schon außerhalb jeder welt in
bricht diese beziehung die eigentlich
nie eine gewesen ist und sie liefert
sich selber in ein kloster ein wie
später erfahre versucht sich dort aus
zogen schimpft immer auf ihren vater und
sagt der vater sei ihr zu nahe getreten
und ich verliere ihre spur und
irgendwann ruft mich dieser vater an und
sagt du musst kommen und ich sage wohin
er sagt wir sind in einem akustischen
dorf der mann war prothese kommen
hierher und besuch uns und rette meine
tochter und ich weiß nicht richtig was
das bedeutet ich reise aber los um den
fuschlsee zu sehen das war der derben
der der see an dem das stattfinden
sollte und ich reise darauf zugreise
darauf zu und stelle irgendwann fest an
dem ufer des sees das kein see mehr ist
sondern dass er ausgetrocknet ist und
das in einem riesigen applaus trocknungs
projekt dieser see als solcher nicht
mehr existierte ich komme in den kleinen
ort dieses abchasische dorf und erfahren
dass die tochter doch mit ihrem vater im
gasthof ist und sie es unter protest
abgelehnt hat mit dem vater allein in
einem zimmer zu schlafen
aus der bekannten vergangenheit und als
ich sage aber warum und du musst doch
hier gesunden und so geht sie mit mir
auf den friedhof und auf dem friedhof
gibt es
zwei familien die dort begraben sind und
plötzlich bekommt sie auf ihre weise
recht also sie bekommen zumindest darin
recht dass es offenbar ein ort war die
durch inzucht soweit einander verbunden
war und schließlich habe ich dann die
recherche aufgenommen nach dem verbleib
dieser frauen sie hat ihren ausweg aus
dem leben dann irgendwann wirklich
gefunden
so wie sie das sehr erzählt haben ist
das ja eine wirklich dramatische
geschichte dieser dieser frau die am
ende dann gestorben ist und als ich die
geschichte buch gelesen hat hat mich das
einfach gewohnt sie sind darunter kreis
an diesem feature see um diese frau zu
helfen
und dieses ganze kapitel das ist 80
prozent landschaft stehen über die
schönheit des financiers und so
beiläufig am ende kommt dann die
begegnung mit der frau und es gerade mal
noch ein halbsatz wo man erfährt dass
sie stirbt im rifaat was ist los mit
diesem willemsen interessieren den
landschaften mehr als menschen
es gibt einen hintergrund dafür erst mal
die entwicklung des plots ist ziemlich
ausführlich also der anfangs erzählt
habe dann komme ich an den fuschlsee und
stelle plötzlich fest der ist die
metapher für das was die frau von sich
selber gesagt hatte ein see den ich für
ein sehr alter und der eine ebene ist
die ausgetrocknet ist und diese frau
hatte sich aushungern wollen die hatte
verschwinden wollen auf eine ähnliche
weise wie dieser sei schließlich
verschwunden ist und insofern wird diese
landschaft zu einer symbolischen
landschaft ich sitze mit der über diesem
see und sehe dass es ein see denn nicht
mehr existiert und die frau beschreibt
sich mich mehr als eine frau die im
studium von kafka allmählich jede
vitalität verliert und verschwindet und
die am ende wirklich weg ist und da habe
ich den eindruck dass der blick auf die
landschaft tatsächlich spiegelung dessen
es was zwischen uns beiden innen
basierte wir wollen jetzt das buch mal
fürs erste hinter uns lassen und uns ein
paar bilder anschauen aus ihrem leben
die mein kollege stars zusammengestellt
guten abend meine damen und herren ich
bin locker lassen
damen herren ungelogen schön habt ihr
euch angezogen das sieht zwar tierisch
festlich aus und bringt euch einigen
applaus
doch im vergleich zum lieben viel zeit
wir nicht mehr als die kopie
willemsen dame in ganz unterschiedlichen
situationen erlebt ich würde ja der
eines herausgreifen wir haben ein paar
bilder gesehen da waren sie in
afghanistan
dass ein land das sie seit jahren
beschäftigt sie haben ein ganzes buch
über die afghanische reise geschrieben
so reisen durch die lande marken
vorträge über afghanistan
wie haben sie dieses land erlebt es ist
mir zunächst mal sehr viel menschlicher
entgegengetreten als man journalistisch
glauben könnte ich habe in den
vermummten männern er die väter und die
brüder gesehen ich habe in den kindern
er die überlebens kämpfer gesehen ich
habe an gewölbte knospen getroffen
kinder die sich noch nicht am entfalten
dürfen und die schon alle spuren des
alterns und des kreisen teams zeigten
ich habe viele traumatisierte frauen
gesehen aber ich gab ihm gleichzeitig
schirmherr des afghanischen
frauenvereins das heißt ich kümmere mich
dort um projekte und ich gehe in die
schulen und ich habe durch viele
begegnungen mit den bürgern den
dorfältesten den taliban glaube ich ein
etwas verändertes bild von dem was
afghanistan ist und das ist nicht
dadurch geleitet dass ich glaube dass
man dort krieg führen soll
vielleicht bevor man auf dem thema krieg
kommen sie haben auch gesagt sie hatten
auch begegnungen mit mit taliban nun ist
taliban ja ungefähr das schlimmste was
man sich im westen vorstellen kann
es waren ihre eindrücke was sind das für
menschen was haben die für eine
mentalität ideologie ich hab das
grässlichsten gesehen dass man auf der
erde sehen kann
in dem was die taliban mit menschen
gemacht haben die im fußballstadion in
den halbzeitpausen die leute auf die
torlatte genagelt haben oder sie
aufgehängt haben die menschen verbrannt
haben im stadion in den halbzeitpausen
es gibt nichts zu beschönigen an dem was
taliban getan haben es gibt auch nichts
daran zu beschönigen dass sie von
amerika finanziert worden sind dass dich
die afghanen die taliban gewählt haben
aber vor allen dingen muss man sagen sie
sind keine homogene gruppe
der amerikanische geheimdienst geht
davon aus es gibt zwischen 6000 und 8000
kämpfende taliban 40 nationen kämpfen
seit zehn jahren gegen diese sechs 8000
personen es gibt also seltener
heerführer es gibt vagabunden die in 25
jahren krieg keine kompetenz haben für
irgendwas anders ich habe festgestellt
dass es taliban gibt die sagen
du darfst eine schule für frauen bauen
dann kann es sein dass im nachbardorf
der nächste sagt nein du darfst das
nicht oder du darf das nur unter den
bedingungen sie sind vollkommen
inhomogen ich hatte ein kurzes gespräch
mit unserem entwicklungshilfeminister
niebel
er sagt ja sie können ja ihre projekte
nur haben weil wir ihnen militärischen
schutz geben dann sage ich wir machen
seit 15 jahren diese projekte das
einzige was wir vom militär haben ist
dass unsere schule beschossen wird weil
es querschläger gibt und sich niemand
entschuldigt wird niemand an den
reparaturarbeiten beteiligt und wir die
eltern überzeugen müssen dann sagt er ja
sie dürfen aber in der schule nur frauen
unterrichten weil wir ihnen den schutz
liefern dann sage ich seit 15 jahren
unterrichten bei uns frauen und wer will
dass die frauen unterrichtet werden die
taliban
weil die taliban sagen zu uns nur wenn
ihr lehrerinnen einstellt haben wir
nicht die befürchtung dass die männer
die mädchen vergewaltigen
das heißt die mögliche sicherheit der
mädchen in der schule ist dadurch
gewährleistet dass frauen sind sie sehen
an diesem kleinen beispiel die zwei mal
die perspektive
völlig falsch ist die uns von höchster
stelle aus auf diesen krieg und auf die
menschen gegeben haben kann ihnen da
nicht widersprechen weil ich selber in
afghanistan war aber was ich immer
wieder höre sind berichte von anschlägen
auf frauen schulen auf mädchen die
bedroht werden weil sie in frauen
schulen gehen ist das dann alles nicht
wahr
also in jedem krieg weites kriege gibt
wird der gegner zu einer übermächtigen
macht aufgebaut und man nimmt die
möglichst sensiblen menschlichen themen
und sagt die frauen sind es um die es
geht hat george bush nicht den frauen im
irak helfen wollen ist nicht gerade usa
klammheimlich aus dem irak rausgegangen
und niemand der in den talkshows
leitartikel vorgelesen hat geht heute
hin und sagt das ist gefährlich was im
moment im irak passiert wie geht es denn
den frauen wie geht es denn der
demokratie im irak gibt es doch
vielleicht al qaida oder gibt es
terroristen die uns gefährden das ist
alles kein thema mehr sondern das ist so
lange thema wie wir begründen müssen
warum soldaten für deutschland
sicherheit in afghanistan sterben und
wenn dann jemand hingeht und sagt es
geht nicht um deutschlands sicherheit
und es geht auch nicht darum dass wir
hier gefährdet werden und ich glaube
auch denen nicht dass die zitternd in
hamburg-altona sitzen und sagen
hoffentlich greifen mich die taliban
nicht an
so hat kriegsmaschinerie immer
funktioniert und wenn man
geisteswissenschaftler ist dann hat man
sich mindestens seit dem ersten
weltkrieg damit auseinandergesetzt wie
man ideologisch kriege vorbereitet ich
würde mir gerne mit ihnen ein titelbild
amerikanische zeitschrift time anschauen
ein paar wochen sehr viel furore gemacht
hat hier haben wir es und die
überschrift lautet was passiert wenn wir
afghanistan verlassen
man sieht eine junge frau aus
afghanistan der der ehemann die nase und
die ohren abgeschnitten hat weil sie
sich nicht unterwerfen wollte ist das
jetzt alles wenn ich sie richtig
verstanden habe propaganda auf der
anderen seite haben sie ja selbst gesagt
das gibt es alles
das ist propaganda also dafür für dieses
mädchen wird keinen krieg geführt und
wer behauptet er täte das der lügt denn
diese menschen die da so etwas schreiben
die vermisse ich in unseren schulen ich
vermisse die staatliche unterstützung
die wir brauchen wenn wir etwas der
gleicht verhindern wollen ich habe so
brutale sachen der taliban erlebt ich
habe so entscheidende führer der taliban
gesprochen und ich kann ihnen sagen
hätte dass selbst der ehemalige
verteidigungsminister struck mir in
keinem punkt hat widersprechen können
als ich ihm gesagt habe wie die
verhandlungen laufen
wer die taliban wirklich sind und was
sie zb bei der auslieferung von osama
bin laden angeboten haben
solche bilder niemand soll uns erzählen
dass zur vermeidung solcher bilder krieg
geführt wird wo wollen sie denn noch
einmarschieren in somalia in jemen im
irak sowie sowie den punkt gebe ich
ihnen man kann ich überall dort
einmarschieren wo die menschenrechte
betont sind aber umgekehrt wenn man in
einem land ist kann man dann so einfach
rausgehen und sagen jetzt seid ihr
wieder euch überlassen weil es ja
vielleicht wenn ich sie richtig
verstanden habe durchaus wahr ist dass
so etwas passieren kann wenn die
bundeswehr jetzt schon heute auf morgen
das gute ist dass die geschichte und
gleich das beispiel gibt und sagt man
geht doch gerade auf dem irak raus genau
auf dieser voraussetzung wer kümmert
sich denn um diese frau wenn sie im irak
ist das ist doch düsterste propaganda
sowas zu behaupten das passiert im irak
im blick und jetzt nehmen sie folgendes
ich sage nicht dass es ein debakel ist
das nicht ein debakel ist wenn wir
afghanen
dann verlassen aber ich sage vor zehn
jahren war afghanistan ein in jeder
hinsicht glücklicheres sicheres land als
es heute ist und wenn afghanistan
verlassen wird und ich verabrede mich
mit ihnen für diesen tisch und wir
werden in zwei jahren afghanistan
verlassen haben und wir werden einen
schlimmeren zustand ein zerstörtes land
mehr tote soldaten mehr tote zivilisten
erleben und dann frage ich sie haben wir
den zustand afghanistans wirklich
verbessert haben wir uns darauf
vorbereitet wer eigentlich dieses land
führen die regieren könnte was möglich
gewesen wäre wenn man nicht ein krieg
gezogen wäre sondern wenn man eine
humanitäre mission als solche so
gelassen hätte wie sie war ein letztes
beispiel als angela merkel sich
entschieden hat überflug tankflugzeuge
nach afghanistan zu schicken um dort
taliban-stellungen auszuforschen haben
wir vom afghanischen frauenverein
aufgeschrien und haben gesagt das ist
der eintritt deutschlands in den krieg
da haben wir die zeitung geschrieben
naja man hilft den amerikanern
man musste ihn irgendwie entgegenkommen
heute wird ihnen jeder in afghanistan
sagen jetzt seid ihr besitzer warum weil
ihr damals angefangen habt militärisch
zu operieren und diesen immensen guten
ruf den die deutschen hatten aus
humanitären gründen zu gefährden es ist
ein fehler
doch zu sein und wir werden auch
voraussetzung aus diesem krieg rausgehen
der uns alle blamiert und jetzt auch
alle gefährdet der islam beschäftigt uns
in dieser ausformung in afghanistan und
jetzt in dieser woche in diesen wochen
in deutschland nicht so sehr der islam
selber sondern das was sarrazin über den
islam sagt wir haben sie diese debatte
erlebt also ich wo tiere ganz stark für
die aufwertung von eva herman
denn ich finde man muss mit dem
lieblingssatz dieser zeit sagen dürfen
das muss man doch noch sagen dürfen
irgendwer jetzt alles auf den löchern
kommt und mit den sätzen das muss man
doch noch sagen dürfen etwas was im
grunde rassenlehre ist als freie
meinungsäußerung deklariert denn was
anderes bedeutet es wenn ich sage
genetisch unterscheidet sich ein jude
von einem muslim
muss man sagen ich hätte nicht gedacht
dass die diskussion auf dieses niveau
herunter fallen würde
ich hätte auch nicht gedacht dass
deutschland in einer massenhysterie und
seit wochen nichts anderes macht als
dafür zu sorgen dass herr sarrazin genug
bücher verkauft das ist unter niveau
dass das mit den genen da hat er ja wohl
auch kaum öffentliche unterstützung
erhalten
da hatte sich selber auch zumindest
teilweise davon distanziert bleibt aber
dass das ein ganzes buch geschrieben hat
400 seiten wo sehr viel anderes auch
geschrieben hat eben auch sehr vieles
über den zustand der integration in der
bundesrepublik deutschland hat
gesprochen über die zusammenhänge
zwischen integration und islam und viele
menschen haben gesagt da könnte was dran
sein oder es ist vieles war an dem was
er sagt wie gesagt nicht unbedingt das
mit den genen aber er hat ja auch andere
dinge gesagt ja also ich weiß nicht wie
sehr ich mich ausgerechnet auf sarrazin
verlassen würde wenn ich etwas über
diesen themenkomplex wissen wollte
sondern ich muss sagen die ideologische
linie dieses buches ist so klar dass man
sagen würde das steht im schatten auch
dessen dass er selber sagt dass buch sei
noch viel drastischer geschrieben worden
und der verlag und seine frau habe ihm
ausgeredet es so zu publizieren wie es
vorgehabt hat ich finde die diskussion
hat sich erübrigt auf der ebene dass man
sagt da ist was wahres dran können wir
uns über alles einigen also wie ich weiß
nicht welche parallelen wir noch finden
würden wenn wir sagen würden da ist was
wahres dran
irgendwas stimmt immer aber die
integration ist auf einem gott sei dank
komplexere niveau inzwischen als das was
sarrazin andeutet und ich frage mich
auch wie jemand der in gepanzerten wagen
durch die hebel durch die elends gebiete
von frankfurt fährt eigentlich wissen
will wie es um die integration bestellt
ist ich habe immer das gefühl das ist
jemand der im grunde sich den kopf
zerbricht über dinge die er nicht kennt
auch von denen er keinen sachverstand
und keine anschauung besetzt und das ist
noch das freundlichste was man dazu
sagen kann also sie sehen keine
zusammenhänge zwischen islam und mehr
integrationsbereitschaft bestimmte
bevölkerungsgruppen weil ich sehe dass
nach dem fall der mauer man gesagt hat
und das können sie überall recherchieren
das nächste feindbild ist der islam und
ich sehe dass es einfach möglich ist
über den islam dinge zu schreiben zu
publizieren die im grunde genommen die
öffentliche diskussion nicht verdient
haben deshalb zurück zu ihrer herrmann
und sagen muss man sich da auch noch mal
neue amt
darüber nachdenken ob die autobahn nicht
wirklich gut waren das muss man doch
noch sagen dürfen
das grotesk meinungsfreiheit daran
festzumachen diskothek und schockiert
sieht das dann dass er offensichtlich in
der bevölkerung einiges an zustimmung
sehr viel zustimmung erhält was man
umfragen ablesen kann an reaktionen auf
fernsehsendungen tausende von e mails an
die spd
ronald schill hat auch viel zustimmung
geerntet und heute will sich niemand
mehr dabei erwischen lassen ihn ehemals
gemacht zu haben
ich weiß nicht bestimmte populistische
problempositionen werden immer eine
zeitlang konjunktur haben und wenn der
prozess von kachelmann tatsächlich
eröffnet worden wäre und nicht vertagt
worden wäre dann hätten wir vielleicht
heute gar keinen sarrazin mehr sein
kachelmann ich weiß nicht ich bin da
desillusioniert genug um zu sagen der
weg der aufklärung geht hoffentlich über
diese gestalten hinweg das war heute im
dialog roger willemsen herzlichen dank
an sie dank an die zuschauer zu hause
nächste woche gibt es wieder einen
dialog